what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich for us
let's just try to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
please
showered clean so fresh and so clean
clean do you know that song
yeah so fresh and so clean clean okay
okay okay uh don't forget the lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto you can deposit krypton earn up
to eight point six percent apy
or you can get a usd loan and get your
crypto collateral go get a block five
account i'm serious you need a block
account if you don't have a wi-fi
account you don't need to go get one
don't even show up here facts go to
blockfit.com
seriously i'm an investor i use the
product go get it block by account block
five dot com slash pomp
it's poppin and if you ain't there you
ain't poppin
go ahead um so just really quickly guys
we are here in this situation because i
accidentally booked
a crack house maybe a crack house i'm
pretty sure that we are staying in it
looked so good in the pictures on airbnb
and it was not cheap so i was like it
must be a real place it is not a real
place
i can't get out now i it's a whole thing
we have transferred responsibilities for
airbnb bookings from
but you approved it you thought it
looked beautiful it does not look
beautiful okay what are we doing
oh and i'm sorry that we didn't record
yesterday we're here today
bitcoin and other digital coins tinked
on monday wiping some 150 billion
dollars off the crypto market
but honestly when people were freaking
out i was like it literally you would
would have been ecstatic
if bitcoin was at this price last week
but now this is the low
and last week it was the high what do
you think
oh my god bitcoin dropped to last week's
prices
everyone freaked out this is stupid it's
a 25
drawdown guess what that happens all the
time literally in 2016 2017 happened
like eight times
over 30 percent so actually it's drawing
down less now than it used to
and when it was trading at 10 000 a 25
percent drawdown meant that it went down
to 7 500
but now when it drops 25 it goes from 40
to 30.
stop freaking out zoom out
chill put your bitcoin on the sidelines
put your glasses
on put your bitcoin on the sidelines
relax go outside for a walk go get
dinner with your significant loved ones
whatever
just chill out also fun fact guys
yesterday was six months since we got
married what
okay so that means we've been doing the
show for more than six months that is
wild
okay um the government on monday was set
to reopen its signature small business
pandemic aid program with 284 billion
dollars in new funding
and revamped rules that aim to get cash
to the most needy businesses while
stamping out fraud and abuse i am very
curious how they're going to try to
stamp out fraud and abuse
small businesses need help but the help
they need is open the damn economy
just open the economy enough is enough
even andrew cuomo that
clown literally the clown who got
ten thousand plus people killed okay
okay
literally is now saying open the economy
come on when did he say that
yeah he's he's tweeting it now now he
said oh we can't continue to keep the
economy closed we must open it to our
small businesses
shut up just open the economy let these
businesses operate
put people in masks tell people to stay
home do whatever you need to do but open
the economy
stop trying to uh uh keep
afloat companies that are bad companies
if somebody's running a bad company you
just keep giving them money and giving
them money and giving them money
you're just perpetuating a bad situation
let the free market run
open the economy let entrepreneurs go to
work and government
get out of the way just get out of the
way
all right ready for the stat let's go
just 39 percent of americans can afford
a 1
000 unexpected expense
uh that result marks a slight decline in
americans ability to
to over emergencies oh cover this
freaking article
to cover emergencies compared to past
years in 2020 41 percent of respondents
said they could afford an
unexpected thousand dollar bill while 40
said the same in 2019 is going down
well so supposedly
um they used to do it on 400 emergency
payment
so maybe there's inflation and even the
emergency payment measurement
no um uh yes it is going down that is a
great thing
no no no no it's not good yeah no it's
good no only 39
can afford to do that it used to be
higher
oh that's right
as we've talked about many times on this
show one of us is not a mathematician
um so so it's getting better it's
improving but it's still not improving
at a significant rate
so it's still bad still about 40 but it
has improved a little bit
the key though to this entire thing no
no
no no hold on a second only 39
can afford to pay a thousand dollars
before 41
could pay it that means if it goes down
it's bad
thank you they can or cannot afford can
afford
a thousand dollar unexpected expense so
39
versus 41 means fewer people
can afford a thousand dollar expense oh
that's not what you said at first you
said can't afford
okay we'll we'll remind the team we will
run the tape but usually what they do
the stat that everyone has previously
talked about is
that fifth it was almost it was just
under 50 of americans
can't afford a 400 emergency payment
so this uh study is even dumber
because now what they're doing is
they're saying who can afford
it so basically it is actually getting
one of those isn't a mathematician
no but you said something different you
can okay she's right
just she's right that just saved me a
lot of pain
uh facts um but it is crazy that
so many people don't have savings beyond
a thousand dollars is ultimately what
that means right
i just don't like that measure because
what it doesn't tell you is um
the other statistic used to say hey they
can't afford a 400
payment without selling uh something
that they own like what you
mean like it has like certain parameters
this doesn't really tell us that much
um but it's bad yes it is very very bad
we know it is bad
uh the fact that uh so many people
are not financially secure is bad
we need to educate people and we need to
teach them
there's five rules that matter right
spend less than you make get out of debt
get multiple streams of income
get out of cash into investable assets
and then stay patient and disciplined
for a long period of time
that's it that's literally the secrets
if you do those five things
you will be set for life and anyone in
the united states
can become a millionaire that's it it's
literally that simple hard to execute
easy to identify
but if you do those five things anyone
can be a millionaire literally you can
do it off of a forty thousand dollar a
year salary
next you know killer mike yes michael
render
is his name um he's an atlanta rapper
now he has teamed up with his longtime
friend ryan glover
and they are responding to a dire need
in communities across the united states
for a modern
black and latinx owned digital banking
platform so they're creating a banking
platform
um it's called the financial services
company is called greenwood and it's
expected to launch later this year
delayed because of covid and
overwhelming early interest
in the project so uh
greenwood is named after the early 20th
century business district in tulsa
oklahoma
that was known as black wall street and
was ultimately destroyed by white mobs
and one of the worst acts of racial
violence in american history
wow this is so interesting everybody
wants a bank now
everybody wants a bank wants a bank yeah
all the fintech the everyone wants a
fintech company everything's getting
financialized
by the way it's a great idea and they
should go out and sign up a million
people that's what i think this is a
great idea
they should keep going that's cool well
look at killer mike
killer mike's that guy got some uh some
ideas and people should help him put his
ideas into uh into practice go ahead
apple is reportedly in talks with
hyundai is that how you say it
hyundai do you like saying that word
hyundai
yes um about cooperating so it's in
talks with hyundai about cooperating on
electric
cars a partnership with the south korean
company makes a lot of sense but it
might not be the only car maker keen to
develop a relationship
with apple why is apple looking at
electric cars
do we not have tesla do we not they're
going to compete with them
really yeah of course they are but why
stick to your phone
no because the car is going to be the
next platform it's a computing platform
do you remember my joke that you didn't
laugh at but everybody found hilarious
where i said that if they create an
electric car
the battery will die over time and get
your car will get slower and slower
until you buy a new car
because the battery poorly
it's so funny the battery life has
nothing to do with the speed of the car
you don't get my joke oh i get the joke
no because of the phone it slows down
your phone when you're battering
you're you're too you're too dry you're
too you two
okay the software on the phone
but remember because tim cook said
something about the battery on the phone
it slows down
okay all right don't make me repeat my
joke and explain my joke
this is not what by the way it's very
funny when i look at you here and
there's a woman with the glasses off
behind your head
all right what's next lunch money time
ask lm
in the comment section oh my god
freak21 asks as a single bitcoin
bachelor how do you find an
honest relationship after going through
such an incredible event of wealth
create
creation good for you freak very envious
of the chemistry you guys have
don't tell anybody cheese don't yeah
don't tell anybody just don't tell
anybody that you have it
yeah like one of our favorite stories is
that sarah blakely uh
and uh what's his name jesse isler uh
sir it's or uh jesse jesus christ
sarah blakely is the founder of spanx
and
uh after they were already engaged
because they met and got engaged very
quickly
yeah as they were about to get married
they went to dinner like a you know a
little bit beforehand
and sarah blakely said uh jesse i really
need to tell you something
and he was like what and jesse uh had
sold a big company and was pretty rich
and he knew about spanx but he didn't
know
how and she said i just need to tell you
this i'm rich
and he was like great so am i like like
congratulations
she was like no no no like i'm like rich
rich
and he was like what do you mean and she
was like i own 100 of my company
and i'm worth over a billion dollars and
he was and he started crying at dinner
because he was so
proud of her that she had literally
become a billionaire
would buy and had raised no dollars from
outside investors
and so it's pretty incredible uh she was
able to wait that long
so just don't tell anybody it's the
easiest way to do it also like jesse you
could have done your research like type
it in google
okay people are asking when
joe rogan ryan lang and jake fever ask
when joe rogan and what do you want us
to do to help you get on joe brogan
i seen that guy asking him to put you on
the show
uh my friend phil uh went on the walrus
whisperer you should go follow him on
twitter he's the man
and uh we'll see if it happens um we are
discussing but uh jamie's hating
jamie isn't uh in the bitcoin crypto i
don't think i think he thinks it's all
uh nonsense so we'll see what happens
but uh stay tuned
nisami asks what are you most looking
forward to in 2021
i'm looking forward to hanging with all
my friends on lunch money
that's literally looking forward to yeah
okay
what are you looking forward to
everybody knows what i'm looking forward
to
oh back one 100k here we come all right
see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends